[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Fußball Champions League das
später bei dir im sportkartja und bilon
genau schön guten Abend dann kommt jetzt
unser
themenüberblick internationale
Bemühungen in Nahost ziel ist eine
Verlängerung der Feuerpause
Bundespräsident Steinmeier dankt Katar
für die
mlung signner Insolvenzantrag schlägt
Wellen der Warenhauskonzern Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof und zahlreiche
Geschäftsimmobilien gehören zur
Unternehmensgruppe und Reife Leistungen
in der Champions League Borussia
Dortmund landet auswärtsuh in Mailand RB
Leipzig verliert nur knapp gegen
Titelverteidiger Manchester
City morgen früh würde die Feuerpause
zwischen Israel und der radikal
islamischen Hamas Auslaufen es deutet
aber viel darauf hin dass das Abkommen
verlängert wird heute wurde hinter den
Kulissen intensiv weiter verhandelt auf
dem israelischen Festivalgelände auf dem
Hunderte durch den Hamas Terror Staben
gab es heute ein besonderes gedenken
Dominik
lmeister jedes Foto steht für einen
getöteten sie legen auf zum Gedenken für
364 von der hermass Ermordete Menschen
auf dem Supernova Festival am 7 oktober
in Tel Aviv hoffen die Angehörigen der
Geiseln auf weitere Freilassungen und
darauf dass die Feuerpause verlängert
wird im Hintergrund wird verhandelt in
Qatar hat sich der Bundespräsident für
eine Verlängerung der Waffenpause
eingesetzt selbstverständlich habe ich
heute meinen Aufenthalt hier und die
Gesprächs Möglichkeiten mit dem Emir von
Qatar
genutzt um zu bitten dass die Bemühungen
insgesamt fortgesetzt werden zur
Befreiung von Geiseln beizutragen aber
dass auch das Schicksal der deutschen
Geiseln
insbesondere berücksichtigt wird Freude
über die Freilassung von Zeh Israelis
sowie zwei Ausländern gestern Hamas
hatte eine weitere Gruppe von Geiseln
dem Roten Kreuz übergeben auch heute
sollen zehn israelische Geiseln sowie
zwei russische Staatsbürger
freikommen wenn diese Phase der Rückkehr
unserer entführten beendet ist wird
Israel dann wieder kämpfen meine Antwort
ist ein eindeutiges JA es besteht keine
Chance dass wir die Kämpfe nicht wieder
auf nehmen bis zum
Ende zwei Vorfälle werden aus dem
Westjordanland gemeldet israel habe
einen ranghohen Kommandeur des
Islamischen Jihad getötet die
Palästinenser sprechen zudem von zwei
Kindern die durch israelische Soldaten
ums Leben kamen unabhängig überprüfen
lässt sich das nicht Hamas behauptet am
Abend dass die Mutter und zwei Kinder
der entführten israelischen Familie
bibas tot sein darunter die jüngste
Geisel das Z Monate alte Baby
vier wegen des Krieges im Nahen Osten
steigt die Gefahr islamistischer
Anschläge in Deutschland das erklärte
der Chef des Bundesamtes für
Verfassungsschutz Haldenwang die Gefahr
sei so hoch wie lange nicht mehr mehrere
Verdächtige hätten sich in den
vergangenen Tagen im Netz über
Anschlagspläne ausgetauscht sie seien
festgenommen worden gegen einen
15-Jährigen aus nordrhein-westfahen
erging
Haftbefehl zum Krieg in der Ukraine
kommen heute bemerkenswerte zahlen die
NATO geht von inzwischen über 300.000
getöteten oder Verwundeten russischen
Soldaten aus wie man die Ukraine besser
und vor allem langfristig unterstützen
kann darum ging es heute im
neugeschaffenen NATO ukrainerat in
Brüssel die Außenminister des Bündnisses
haben mit ihrem Kollegen aus Kiev
beraten Ulf Röller berichtet herzliche
Begrüßung des ukrainischen
Außenministers die Gesten sind eindeutig
bei der NATO aber aber die
Militärallianz ist besorgt denn der
Stellungskrieg fordert hohe
Verluste wir sollten Russland nicht
unterschätzen wir müssen uns auf neue
Luftangriffe einstellen deshalb ist es
wichtig der Ukraine unsere Solidarität
nicht nur mit Worten sondern auch mit
Taten zu
beweisen eine Warnung denn in Wahrheit
wirkt das festliche Bündnis kriegsmüde
vor allem der innenpolitische Streit in
den USA droht weitere Militärhilfen zu
die Ukrainer hat niemand gebeten auch
nicht die USA Soldaten zu schicken das
unterscheidet uns von anderen unser
Angebot ist doch sehr fair ihr schickt
uns die Waffen wir
kämpfen der Ukraine droht ein Engpass
bei der Munition von zugesagten eine
Million
Artilleriegranaten haben die
Bündnispartner bislang wohl erst rund
300000 geliefert die Ukraine braucht
mehr
waffenut damit bereits intensiv begonnen
durch weitere Lieferung von Patriots
durch weitere Lieferung auch von zivilen
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen wie Generatoren
und ich rufe erneut weltweit dazu auf
alles dafür zu tun gemeinsam für die
Ukraine diesen winterschutzschirm zu
spannen der Ukraine steht ein schwerer
Winter bevor jeder im Bündnis weiß nur
mit Hilfe kann sie ihn
durchstehen ja während man also in
Brüssel diskutiert muss die Ukraine
tagtäglich russische Angriffe abwehren
an mehreren Frontabschnitten im Osten
des Landes verstärkte Russland seine
Attacken etwa auf
avdivka die russischen Truppen versuchen
die Stadt komplett einzukesseln und noch
halten ukrainische Soldaten dort die
Stellung über einen der am heftigsten
umkämpften Orte des Landes berichtet
jetzt Tim
Kröger fast täglich fahren die Judin und
von der Poli zeieinheit weiße Engel in
das schwer umkämpfte abdivka sie retten
Menschen und bringen Hilfsgüter in die
Stadt das Risiko fährt immer
mit in der letzten Zeit greift die
feindliche russische Armee hier immer
intensiver mit Drohnen
an weiter dürfen wir nicht mitfahren sie
drehen selbst das Ausmaß der Zerstörung
in der Stadt ist unfassbar aufdka ist
schon lange umkämpft seit Oktober aber
versuchen tausende russische Soldaten
unter hohen Verlust die Stadt
einzukesseln der russische Präsident
Putin braucht Erfolge die etwa 1300
verbliebenen Menschen schlafen in
Kellern und kämpfen um das
Überleben es wird hier jeden Tag
geschossen sowohl in der Stadt als auch
außerhalb Häuser brennen ab sie werden
zerstört Menschen kommen dabei ums
Leben die weißen Engel bringen Wasser
und Diesel für die Generatoren in das
Krankenhaus der Stadt noch immer Haren
hier Ärzte und Schwestern aus versorgen
Patienten und bereiten sich auf den
Winter
vor wir sind bereit wir haben üfen und
Generatoren Brennholz und
Kohle Rückkehr aus afdka in der
Dunkelheit genadi und dmitro stammen
selbst aus der Stadt gehen deshalb die
Gefahr ein und hoffen dass es die
ukrainische Armee Schaft afdka irgendwie
zu
halten wie und womit das klaffende
Milliardenloch nächsten Bundeshaushalt
gestopft werden soll darüber wird seit
dem finanzurteil aus Karlsburg gerätselt
und gestritten in etwa anderthalb
Stunden treffen sich die ampelspitzen
und beraten wie sie den Haushalt 2024
aufstellen und wo eingespart werden
könnte wir gehen nach Berlin zu
shakuntala benergi shakuntala womit ist
da heute Abend zu rechnen wenn SPD Grüne
und FDP über die Finanzen beraten es ist
fast einfacher zu sagen womit nicht zu
rechnen ist nämlich es es nicht zu
rechnen mit einem fertigen Haushalt 204
20 davon gehen nicht einmal die
Teilnehmer aus dass sie das heute in
einer Abendsitzung hinbekommen dabei ist
der Druck allerdings sehr hoch dass sie
zumindest ein Zwischenergebnis oder so
etwas wie einen Fahrplan zur Erstellung
eines Haushalts fürs nächste Jahr
zurecht bekommen heute Abend denn die
Lücke die da klafft fürs nächste Jahr
die ist ja relativ groß wir haben in den
letzten Wochen immer wieder gehört von
einem Korridor von ungefähr 15 bis 24
Milliarden je nach Schätzung die SPD
geht mittlerweile soweit dass sie von
einem höheren zweistell gegen Milliarden
Betrag spricht das wäre also noch einmal
deutlich mehr und da gilt es heute Abend
mindestens mal zwei Dinge zu klären
nämlich zum einen wie viel Geld fehlt
denn jetzt genau für das kommende Jahr
und hat die Ampel eigentlich Vorschläge
die ausreichen um diese Lücke dann m zu
füllen bisher dreht sich ja auch vieles
um die Frage Schuldenbremse ja oder nein
muss man da noch mal für die nächste für
das nächste Jahr eine Ausnahme machen
SPD und Grüne drängen sehr wenn sich
heute rausstellen sollte dass die
Vorschläge noch nicht reichen für das
fehlende Geld dann wird das sicherlich
auch noch mal ein Thema sein das auf den
Tisch kommt schakunter da lieben Dank
nach Berlin und es ist sicherlich
spannend was der Finanzminister in
diesem Zusammenhang zu sagen hat gleich
stellt er sich nämlich den Fragen von
bertina Schausten und Anne gellineck in
was nun Herr Lindner direkt nach uns um
19:20 Uhr geht's
los die Inflation in Deutschland die
geht weiter zurück im November stiegen
die Verbraucherpreise um
3,2% im gleich zum Vorjahresmonat das
ist der niedrigste Stand seit fast
zweieinhalb Jahren dem Preisanstieg
steht inzwischen ein höheres Lohnplus
gegenüber im dritten Quartal legten die
Reallöhne um 0,6% zu es ist der zweite
Anstieg
infolge es ist eine Pleite die
Finanzmärkte und Innenstädte erschüttern
könnte die österreichische Signal
Holding die ist insolvent der Kopf
hinterseger das ist ren Benko zum
Konzern gehören hunderte Unterfirmen und
viele Immobilien in Hamburg ist die
signalgruppe etwa am Bau des Elb Towers
beteiligt auch der Warenhauskonzern
Galleria gehört zum Firmenimperium was
die Insolvenz für Mitarbeiter und
Projekte bedeutet dazu Thomas münten der
Hamburger elbtauer eines der
Leuchtturmprojekte die die siegnergruppe
in Deutschland gerade umsetzen will und
deren Zukunft völlig unklar ist genauso
wie die der Galeria karstad Kaufhof hier
sollten im Januar noch mal 200 Millionen
Euro in die Sanierung fließen wenn das
Geld nicht kommt sehen
Wirtschaftsexperten schwarz ja man muss
immer ergänzen dass wir im Augenblick
die Weihnachtssaison haben da wird eine
Menge an Liquidität auch in die Galeria
reingespült aber nach Weihnachten gehen
nicht nur die Weihnachtskerzen aus
sondern auch die Liquidität und dann
wird es sehr düster aussehen rund 42000
Mitarbeiter hat die Gruppe weltweit wie
viele Arbeitsplätze mittelbar am
Unternehmen hängen lässt sich nur schwer
beziffern der Gesamtwert der Gruppe
liegt nach eigenen Angaben bei 77
Milliarden Euro das Unternehmen setzt
auf große Nachfrage Niedrigzinsen und
hohe
Immobilienwerte wir hab mittlerweile
hohe Zinsen
Immobilienpreise sind nicht mehr so
erzielbar die Baukosten steigen und dann
bricht so ein Gebäude wie ein Kartenhaus
zusammen ob das Schlemm und
flaniererlebnis am Gänsemarkt in Hamburg
jemals Wirklichkeit wird ist heute
genauso unklar wie die Frage ob ein
Hamburger Investor wie angekündigt in
den Weiterbau des elbtowers
einsteigt wir wollen jetzt noch mal
nachfragen bei stefhanie Barrett in
Frankfurt an der Börse stefhanie sner
ist Europas größter privater
Immobilienkonzern was hängt da aus
deutscher Perspektive jetzt alles dran
also für zahlreiche Banken und Baufirmen
steht schon einiges auf dem Spiel zu den
deutschen Kredit gebern gehören
verschiedene zur Sparkassengruppe
zählende Landesbanken sie sind wohl mit
einem mittleren dreistelligen
Millionenbetrag involviert offizielles
gibt es dazu nicht dass aber eine
Deutsche Bank wegen signa in
existenzbedrohende Schieflage geraten
könnte das scheint derzeit
ausgeschlossen denn die signgruppe hat
laut Experten keinen signifikanten
Einfluss auf die
Finanzmarktstabilität für die
Beteiligten baauunternehmen sieht es
dagegen nicht gut aus viele befinden
sich ja ohnehin schon im krisenmodus und
wenn jetzt noch eine Reihe von
Großprojekten in Gefahr ist dann
belastet das natürlich die gesamte
Branche was diesen Fall so problematisch
macht ist eben auch die intransparente
Buchhaltung der signgruppe es er handelt
sich nicht nur um ein weit verzweigtes
fast dschungelartiges Firmengeflecht aus
Immobilien Sport und Medienunternehmen
ren Benko ist es auch gelungen seine
Unternehmensbilanzen im Verborgenen zu
halten und hier müssen sich sicherlich
auch Wirtschaftsprüfer und Steuerberater
unangenehme Fragen gefallen lassen
Stefanie lieben Dank und Grüße nach
Frankfurt Minusgrade Matsch und Eis
morgentliche Verkehrsbehinderung der
Wintereinbruch macht weiterhin vielen zu
schaffen bei Hannover hatten etliche PKW
und LKW auf glatten Fahrbahnen Probleme
mit Steigungen die Folgen lange Staus
und abschleppmanöver vor allem im Norden
kam es zu Unfällen meist mit
glimpflichem Ausgang außerdem gab es
nicht alltägliche Impressionen die
sülter Küste ganz in weiß mit wogenem
Salzwasser nebst eisduschen in
Zuckerguss sehr schön ja und in östers
und Schweden ist es auch immer schön ne
oder ja vor allem wenn die deutschen
Biathletinnen erfolgreich sind sie
knüpfen nahlos an die Erfolge vom
vergangenen Wochenende an heute sicherte
sich die deutsche Staffel über 4 x 6 km
Platz 3 hinter den Quartetts aus
Norwegen und
Schweden hinter einer erfolgreichen
staffelleistung steckt ein ganzes Team
Schlussläuferin Franziska PR profitiert
zum ein von der guten Vorarbeit ihrer
Kolleginnen und einem schwächeemoment
der Schwedin öberg die in Führung
liegend in die Strafrunde muss so kommt
es zu einem harten Kampf auf der
Schlussrunde preus gegen die laufstarke
Schwedin hanna öberg ist halt Hanna
öberg das war mir schon bewusst dass ich
da läufis glaub ich nur ein kürzeren zi
aktuell ja ich habe schon gekämpft bis
zum Schluss aber ja sie war heute schon
deutlich stärker hart gekämpft haben
auch die Norwegerinnen mit
Schlussläuferin landmar handrevolt
deutlich der Vorsprung auf die zweit
platzierten Schwedinnen das deutsche
Quartett freut sich über Rang
3 und morgen ist die Männerstaffel dran
live hier im ZDF von 15:5 Uhr an das
Internationale Olympische Komitee hat
vor wenigen Minuten Frankreich als
Gastgeber für die Olympischen
Winterspiele 2030 und die USA für 204
vorgeschlagen die endgültige
Entscheidung darüber gibt's dann im
kommenden Jahr in der Fußball Champions
League hat RB Leipzig Titelverteidiger
Manchester City ins Wanken gebracht der
aber blieb standhaft Leipzig führte in
Manchester 2:0 verlor am Ende 2:3 und
der BVB hatte beim AC Mailand mindestens
zwei Garanten für den 3:1 Erfolg einen
Hummels und einen
Torhüter hätte Matz Hummels nicht einen
absolut brillanten Tag erwischt und
hätte Gregor Kobel nicht in der sechsten
Minute diesen Meter entschärft wäre
vielleicht alles ganz anders gekommen so
aber zeigte der BVB sein bestes Gesicht
Marco Reus verwandelte sicher zur ein
zu0 Führung ein berechtigter Meter ein
Rückschlag der Ausgleich von Samu
schukvze der aber gut kompensiert wurde
nach toller Ballstafette ein präziser
Schuss von Jamie Bino gittens zum
2:1 den Schlusspunkt setzte der
eingewechselte Karim adiemi der Ball
eindeutig drin genauso wie der BVB im
Achtelfinale und heute spielen noch die
Bayern und Union Berlin zu sehen im
Champions League Magazin 23:10 Uhr heute
okay gut danke Katja wir haben noch die
Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto und so gehen
die 3 22 25 29 45 49 Superzahl lautet 7
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zf.de oder auf der ZF Textseite
557 dann blicken wir jetzt aufs Wetter
im Süden länger andauernde Schneefälle
teils auch Regen mit sehr großer
Glättegefahr im Norden sonnige
Abschnitte und nur einzelne
Schneeschauer -2 bis + 4° die
Temperaturen und die weiteren Aussichten
vor allem im Süden weitere kräftige
Schneefälle oder gefrierender Regen das
heute journal heute um
21:55 mit Christian sieers das war's von
uns schönen Dank fürs zuschauen und bis
morgen und jetzt geht's hier direkt weit
mit was nun Herr
[Musik]
Lindner